[موسيقى]
صبا الذي كان محطه اهتمامي اكثر من غيره
كان منصبه وزيره الدفاع الذي شغلته لمده
خمسه اعوام وهي الوزاره الاكثر تكاملا حيث
نهتم فيها بالمسائل الدوليه والاستراتيجيه
ولكن ايضا بالشؤون التي لها صله بالبحث
العلمي وصناعه الاسلحه والمشاكل
الاقتصاديه والمسائل المتعلقه بالمعدات
ولا سيما منها في بلد يمتلك سلاح النويا
وهذا امر مهم في هذه الفتره كانت هناك
الكثير من العمليات في افغانستان التي
زرتها مرارا وفي الكونغو في افريقيا في
لبنان وتشاده اذا في كل الاماكن في الخارج
ومنها كسوف في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
تم طرح اسميك رئيسه للوزراء وكان ذلك حتى
في عهد شراك في العام 2006 وبعد ذلك تم
تعيين دومينيك دولبا لماذا هذا الامر ليس
من سماتي اي ممارسه الضغوط للحصول على هذا
المنصب او ذاك المناصب كلها التي تم
اقتراحها علي لم اطالب بها وعلينا ان نقر
انه كان هناك رئيسه وزراء سابقه انا احب
دائما ان اكون الاولى لان هذا الامر يشكل
اضافه بالنسبه لي اعتقد ايضا انه كان في
محيط جاك شيراك
ربما لان رئيسه الوزراء الاشتراكيه
السابقه لم يخالفها الحظ وبالنظر الى صفات
القويه ربما لم يحصل ذلك
[موسيقى]